jaquet bonjour et bienvenue donc je me
présente rapidement donc moi je
m'appelle les si je suis là c'est parce
que on était ensemble en fait on
pourrait pas et parce que aussi j'ai une
chaîne qui s'appelle cnce warhol il
parle de maths donc invités à les voir
réunis tube jeu qui marche bien et
aujourd'hui nous sommes ravis de vous
parler avant pour introduire razvan ce
sera à cesser de tout ce qu'ils avaient
avant enigma est pourquoi est-ce qu'on
en est venu à enigma pourquoi est-ce
qu'un animaux c'est un peu une solution
naturelle qui est venu aux ingénieurs
allemands pour de 1918 donc avant de
commencer un petit contexte historique
et c'est de mettre un peu l'ambiance on
va voir ce que ça va donner
donc ça c'est une image de seconde
guerre mondiale quel jour exactement
pour un single 6 juin 44 c'est le
débarquement en normandie
votre cas c'est une représentation du
débarquement en normandie puisque le
débarquement en normandie a eu lieu la
nuit nuit c'est facile d'attaquer de
nuit donc il n'y avait pas de
photographe pour prendre les photos
alors la tête du du 6 juin 1940 il est
très important c'est un tournant
important de ailleurs parce que c'est le
moment où les alliés vont enfin mettre
le pied sur la partie occidentale de
l'europe partie continentale de laura et
ce qui était dit vicat c'est qu' il n'y
avait pas 36 façons de débarquer n'y
avait pas 36 endroit où débarquent et
toute la côte était déjà occupée par les
nazis
image prise de c'est pas sorcier héros
particulier bah ouais c'est un peu juste
cette partie là qui était intéressante
pour les pour l'e book pour les alliés
pour débarquer parce qu'il faut savoir
que vous imaginez vous débarquez avec
beaucoup de navires faut regrouper tous
les navires il ya énormément de
logistique à mettre en place
vous pouvez vous avez vous pouvez pas
faire une opération qui va durer trois
jours parce que sinon il faut ramener
tous les ravitaillements pour trois
jours pour préparer toute la bouffe les
tout ça pour tout le monde
il faut fois faut que ça soit proche en
tant que ça soit ça puisse être rapide
et du coup il n'y a pas beaucoup de
destinations possibles le plus proche
ici c'est calais calais c'était le plus
proche c'était là c'est facile à la
solution de base euros et sauf qu'ils
ont d'abord débarqué en normandie parce
qu'ils sont dit qu'à calais il y aurait
sans doute trop de trop de forces nazies
que ce serait un carnage
alors ils ont même fait un peu mieux que
ça si vous savez ce qu'ils ont essayé de
faire pour pouvoir être sûr de débarquer
tranquillement oui ils ont fait ils ont
fait diversion
ils ont mis ils ont donné l'impression
qu'ils ont fait toute une flotte et des
dés des tanks en carton pour donner
l'impression que le débarquement elle
avoir lieu à calais ils ont même fait un
peu mieux que ça ils ont laissé échoué
décor dans la méditerranée et avec en
fait ils ont façonné des décors déjà
mort mais ils ont vêtu d'uniformes comme
cité les uniformes alliés ils ont mis
des documents à l'intérieur qui donne l
impression que débarquement allait avoir
lieu à calais et à ce moment et en rosé
tout faire ils ont tous ils ont fait
toute une campagne de communication de
propagande pour donner l'impression que
la takaléa l'homme allait avoir lieu à
calais sauf qu'ils assuraient ne pouvez
pas être sûr que tu que les nazis aller
mordre à l'hameçon visite avait pour
vraiment s'assurer que l'attaquant
allait bien se passer il devait se voir
ce qui se passait dans la tête des nazis
et c'est là que le décodage des codes
nazis par notamment turing a permis de
savoir ce qui se passait dans la tête
des nazis et de se dire la normandie le
6 juin
si vous débarquez le 5 juin devant le 6
20 c'était la bonne date c'était le bon
moment pour pour pour attaquer les nazis
alors vous parle de ça parce que c'est
un peu spectaculaire mais la plus grande
contribution en fait due
du décodage des codes des nazis c'est
pas ça en fait le plus grand plus grande
contribution c'est peut-être davantage
le décodage des codes de la marine nazis
faut se rendre compte que avant 1944
enfin 1944 déjà les alliés sont bien
partis quand on veut on sent qu'elle est
les alliés ont quand même un pad avance
mais avant 44 n'était pas forcément le
cas en particulier à ce moment là les
américains n'étaient pas encore en gare
quand les américains n'étaient pas
encore en guerre
vous imaginez que le rapport de forces
est peu était pas tout à fait le même en
particulier à ce moment là les
britanniques voient y avait les
soviétiques d'un côté et puis les
britanniques étaient un peu la dernière
force qui restait des alliés de l'autre
côté et les britanniques étaient en
train de sombrer petit à petit à cause
de quoi d'après vous oui un blocus et
donc la famille fait le gros problème
des britanniques
à ce moment là si j'étais juste de
manger c'était juste dit avoir de fin
des des biens de base pour pouvoir
survivre et en le problème c'est que
pendant la guerre bat il pouvait pas
envoyer tous leurs leurs paysans
cultiver les terres et du coup le plus
simple c'était essayer d'avoir des
alliés des américains qui leur envoyer
de la nourriture et donc il aura envoyé
de la nourriture via des bateaux sauf
que le problème c'est que les nazis
avaient énormément de sous marins pour
tout l'atlantique qui qui descendait
beaucoup de des bateaux et winston
churchill premier ministre anglais cette
époque là disait que la seule chose
qu'il craignait il leur a dit plus tard
que la seule chose s'il craignait
vraiment pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale c'étaient les navires les les
sous-marins nazis ce que les sous-marins
nazis pouvait mettre les britanniques
dans une situation telle qu'ils auraient
été forcés de capituler ou en tout cas
ça aurait été beaucoup plus dur pour les
britanniques et beaucoup d'historiens
qui estime que en décodant enigma en
fait les cryptographes britanniques ont
pu savoir où étaient les nazis les
sous-marins nazis du coup pour pouvoir
il suffisait de les éviter faut vous
savez où sont les sous marins c'est très
facile
vous les éviter et du coup le
ravitaillement des forces britanniques
étaient beaucoup plus faciles et selon
certains historiens ça ça a permis de
réduire la de raccourcir la gare de 2 à
4 ans voire d'en changer le sort donc là
vous voyez quand même un exemple ou
décodage d'un code notamment par des
mathématiciens en parlant du ring a
permis est vraiment de changer peut-être
le cours de l'humanité
en tout cas de sauver enfin deux ou
quatre ans de guerre sachant que pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale c'étaient des
dizaines de millions de morts par an
ça représente des dizaines de millions
de vies qui sont sauvées par par le
travail de décodage futur et essayer
qu'on les essais et ses compères donc
vraiment je pense que c'est un épisode
assez remarquable sur l'effet des
mathématiques dans nos sociétés et
aujourd'hui encore cet effet des
mathématiques est peut-être encore plus
important que jamais aujourd'hui avec
internet et tout ça alors donc ça
c'était l'introduction un peu historique
donc on va un peu en retrait dans le
bain on va parler de coup de codage
assez simple donc ça c'est un code à ses
seins parce que quelqu'un est capable de
décoder ccc jules césar
jules césar donc le fallait remonter
trois lettres rouges
une réponse trop tôt quelques secondes
protocole était donc le codage de césar
dont vous connaissez donc c'est un
collage para para décalage l'idée c'est
qu'on a des lettres où on écrit des
lettres de l'alphabet ont fait copier
coller et puis on décale donc ici en
fait il décalé de trois unités vers la
droite pour pouvoir décoder le message
donc quand il ya x y z acquis les passes
on le remet au début et ensuite on
traduit le m2 virgile x devient rue et
ainsi de suite
ça donne du le césar combien y at-il de
code de césar 26 26
j'ai écrit 26 mai 26 dont un qui est
bien sûr trivial qui est du code qui
consiste à rien faire c'est souvent
utile en maths de compter les trucs
triviaux trio ça veut dire évidemment
c'est quoi qui fait mais c'est souvent
utile de considérer qu trio parce que ça
simplifie souvent le comptage même les
structures des objets mathématiques donc
pour pouvoir décoder ça si on savait que
c'était un code de césar à suffisait de
tester toutes les possibilités
il y en a 26 donc c'est faisable ça
prend un peu de temps pour que vous nous
est arrivé assez vite mais ça prend
menée voilà
et puis il ya un seul mot bizarrement
dans tous ces mots une à un seul on a un
seul qui qui qui en un sens ce quelque
chose comme quelque chose d'assez
remarquable sur la langue française sont
propriétés de la langue finalement le
fait que sur 26 tirage au sort comme
forme on pourra considérer des tirages
au sort
enfin il y en a un qui était en fait
reconnaissable
alors une petite remarque sur le cas de
césar la manière de coder le code de
césar ça consiste à décoller le
deuxième alphabet de trois rangs vers la
gauche ont bizarrement ça décale 3 vers
la gauche
sachant que l'autre c'était vers la
droite on en veut dire que c'est moins
trois une certaine heure on a fait 3 - 3
en est revenu au point de départ
un peu comme si on avait additionné de
code de décalage et là je vous parle
d'addition ça peut paraître un peu
bizarre mais c'est une vraie addition
enfin c'est une addition qui très très
très étudiée en fait et razvan vous
parlera de non pas l'addition de
décalage mais la composition de
permutations verra ça alors un autre
code qui est assez connue est sans doute
vu c'est code par substitution
donc là cette fois ci on va mélanger les
kills et des lettres en bas
combien y at-il de et donc comment
ensuite pour parko des vents le gie on
regarde là ils associés aux cellules
associés ou thé et ainsi de suite
donc ça me donne le message codé combien
y at-il de code de substitution 26
factorielle expliqué juste un peu leur
raisonnement rapidement des rares
satisfaction réelle oui exactement donc
donc en fait proche avec la première
lettre on a 26 possibilité 25 parades
deuxième exercice de suite jusqu'à la
dernière lettre
mais plus qu'une possibilité donc c'est
ce qu'on arrête aussi 26 factorielle
avec un point d'exclamation
vous avez une idée de combien ça fait à
peu près 26 factorielle petit estimation
à la louche
sans calculatrice
ça fait quoi a fait cent mille 20
millions à 1 milliard milliards on voit
il ya vingt-six nombre est assis on est
très approximatif leur ordre de grandeur
à chaque fois ça peu près 10 on
multiplie d'yves 26 nombre tous à peu
près 10 c'est à peu près 10 puissance 26
à la louche estimation à la louche
en fait c'est pas loin de la vérité
parce que je mets ces résultats donc en
fait c'est 4 x 10 puissance 26 alors
qu'elle 3 à 10 puissance 26 c'est
beaucoup évidemment dire mais c'est
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
qu'un milliard ou par exemple si on se
mettait toute l'humanité ensemble les
combos chacun avait attesté un une
possibilité de décodage par son
utilisation par seconde pour ce qui sera
très rapide ou plutôt si on donnait un
ordinateur le lac la tâche de tester
toutes ces combinaisons
sachant qu'un ordinateur fait à peu près
un milliard d'opérations par seconde les
giga hertz soit ordinaire
ça fout il faudrait quand même
discussion de 26 / 10 puissance note que
c'est la vitesse qui fait 10 puissance
17 secondes 10 6 ans 17 secondes ça fait
en année combien peu près à la louche
des idées
j'ai juste vu la solution cette phase a
fait ça fait des milliards d'années de
calcul en gros un milliard de seconde
c'est à peu près une année
est-ce que je suis donc la vitesse des
ordinateurs a disposé que c'était un
gigahertz giga gigas et 1 milliard
hertz et par seconde un air de je suis
partout donc certains des milliards
d'années de calcul même pour un
ordinateur donc ce n'était pas faisable
même par un ordinateur moderne n'aurait
pas que j'avais pas d'ordinateur moderne
donc mais bon avec l'om tout site où le
uk tout le royaume uni se mettant
ensemble pour essayer d'aider cause du
truc il y serait jamais arrivé on attend
raisonnable vous pouvez voir aussi la
probabilité de trouver une réponse au
bout d'un an c'est un sur trois
milliards
aucune chance alors comment casser un
code par six solutions on peut pas
tester toutes les possibilités on peut
pas utiliser son appel d'offres force
brute du coup fait un peu pesante et
bien oui
la méthode d'al kindi qui consiste à
exactement ce que je vais faire c'est
que je suppose et que vous aviez trouvé
comme ça ça vous va vers nous pour
avancer donc donc normalement vous
auriez dû trouver cette phrase vous
préconisez donc c'est sûr vous auriez
réussi si vous avez plus de temps
cette méthode permet vous savez
s'appelle ces méthodes d'al kindi qui
était un savant perse donc à bagdad à la
maison dès sa jeunesse au 9e siècle donc
à cette époque là le bagdad en
particulier et puis l' empire musulman à
cette époque là était au sommaire
c'était là qu'est tout le savoir été
regroupés pour plusieurs raisons
notamment parce que la religion poussé
beaucoup les savants à s'informer à
cette époque là mais aussi parce que
bagdad était en fait au carrefour des
civilisations il essaie de récupérer les
manuscrits des grecs anciens à l'ouest
de l'egypte et ils ont récupéré aussi
tout savoir des indiens et des chinois
l'est et notamment l es salam époque y
avait aussi à même époque il y avait un
autre sens de la maison des crs qui
s'appelait al khwarizmi qui a donné le
mot pour apa le gorille cette crise mais
si je prononce mieux c'est un truc du
genre à trois ris n'est pas trop essayé
mais en gros c'est ce qui a été
transformé en algorithmes et à cette
époque-là d'énormément de persée qui ont
été faites dans la compréhension de deux
de ses mathématiques
le principe de base d'énigmes si vous
connaissez mais le principe de base
d'énigmes à c'est que on va essayer de
trouver un codage qui qu'on ne peut pas
casser avec cette méthode par anaïs de
fréquence est l'astuce d'enigma pour ce
faire c'est de changer la permutation
qui va être utilisé pour chaque lettre
donc en gros on va avoir un espèce de
cahiers comme ça où donc l'alphabet dans
l'ordre et à chaque ligne
il ya une nouvelle permutation des
lettres et pour la première lettre on va
utiliser la première ligne pour la
deuxième liaison va utiliser la deuxième
ligne et ainsi de suite
c'est clair du coup hop si je demande
d'encoder al kindi
ça va commencer par x et y
le cas a été déraciné suite oui alors
vous pouvez demander à du coup mais
quant aux doudous d'où vient ce qu'on
vient de ces lettres uniquement c'est
une machine c'est pas des phrases toutes
faites
l'astuce d'énigmes en fait c'est d'avoir
une machine qui à voir nous confient des
configurations en interne fait avoir 3 3
ou à 3 rotors à chaque fois vous tapez
une lettre et un rotor qui va tourner et
ça va changer la configuration est en
fait quand j'écris ça la première ligne
ça correspond au fait que dans la
configuration initiale de la machine
enigma si j'appuie sur le assad vient x6
j'appuyais sur un b ça devenait un e
mais sa marque pas la configuration
initiale dès que j'appuie sur un bouton
il ya un rotor qui tourne et ça ça
correspond à la deuxième ligne si
j'appuie sur un train de moutons ça va
être tourné encore sont pressés à 3,2 me
et ainsi de suite
alors il m'a c'est une machine finit
donc d'un moment en fait fait le premier
retorse ne l'aurait faire un tour il va
entraîner le deuxième retour puis le
deuxième moteur pour aller faire un tour
il va entraîner le troisième rotor et
quand le 3d motors a fait un tour on
sera retrouvée retournée à la situation
de départ en fait d'un chat rotor avait
26 position parce que mon 26 lettres de
l'alphabet et du coup le nombre de
configurations possibles d'enigma de
configuration initiale en tout cas c'est
26 pour apprendre le premier rotor x 26
pour la deuxième fois 26 pour le
troisième donc 26 26 à fait 676 soit 26
a fait 17 milles 576 me croyais je n'ai
appris avant de venir j'ai pas une
machine à calculer et et sauf que c'est
pas ton donc enigma donc les ja cerro
torre
mais en fait c'est retour en fait on
peut les mettre dans l'ordre que l'on
veut le truc c'est que une fois que vous
avez choisi l'ordre lorsque vous tapez à
resteront dans cet ordre mais avant de
de choisir applications clés choisir
l'ordre un call home et enigma lors des
ces trois auteurs dont il ya trois
rotors combien y at il de façon
désordonnée 6 3 pour le premier deux
pour deuxième vingt pour le dernier et
encore un autre truc dans l'énigme à
skis c'est ce qu'on appelle le club
board
donc on a les 26 lettres de l'alphabet
et on peut les joindre avec des câbles
on peut former n'importe quel père que
l'on veut et au début nigma avait si ici
câble du coup on peut former six paires
que l'on veut avec avec ce câblage et
donc ça ça fait combien de câblage
possible je suis pas habitué à ce genre
de classe de la fuite quand je pose des
questions en classe personne ne répond
plus personne ne réfléchit rétroactif et
oui il ya quelqu'un qui unit des dominés
par un facteur réel première proposition
à battre oui
voici les quais alors que quand est ce
qu'on vous propose une autre façon de
conter en fait ce n'est pas les bonnes
réponses
on va essayer d'avancer un petit peu
marre de donc donc donc pour pouvoir
compter les pères en fait on va choisir
d'abord les lettres une par une donc
nous imaginons maintenant imaginez on a
un câble avec le câble il faut mettre
une mixture une première lettre
et puis l'autre bout à une deuxième neuf
donc par exemple imaginons que je
veuille mettre par exemple eu avec le
haut
ça c'est mon premier câblage ensuite je
prends un deuxième câble
et puis donc je branche le r avec le n
est ainsi de suite
je vais mettre une troisième paire
dompter avec le q3 une fois que j'aurai
fait tout mais câblage ne soit écrit si
l'être mais y at il de façon différente
décrire combien y at il de façon
d'écrire dans doucet tous cas c'est
dommage combien utile de façon d'écrire
12e dans l'ordre comme ça
j'ai 26 possibilités de choix de la
première lettre 25 pour la 2e 24 fois 3e
23 il ya 12 est donc à 26 facteurs et /
14 facture elle façon de choisir ses
douze lettres dans l'ordre une fois que
j'ai cet ordre je sais en fait quel est
le câblage que je vais utiliser le
problème c'est que il ya plusieurs
ordres possible des lettres pour obtenir
le même câblage
par exemple si si j'avais écrit à eux à
la place de haut
j'aurais eu exactement le même câblage
ok en fait pour chaque paire jeu peut
inverser les lads donc pour chaque paire
en fait je vais compter deux fois pour
chaque sphère du comté de foix
donc il ya six paires faut que je fait
jeudi vie sera encore par deux puissants
62.6 correspondent chacun d'eux me
correspond à l'inversion de l'être dans
une paire et c'est pas tout aussi parce
que j'aurais pu écrire eux au pq rm son
effet même câblage donc l'ordre dans
lequel j'ai choisi mes pairs ça donne le
même câblage combien y at il de façon de
redonner ses pairs
si factorielle si choix de la première
perd 5 pour la deuxième et ainsi de
suite
vous pouvez diviser par 6 factorielle si
je récapitule tout ça ça ne fait qu à
trois choix pour le premier rotor dont
il sort des rotors 2 pour le deuxième
pour le troisième l'a 26 positions
possibles du premier rotor 26 positions
possibles du 12e 26 pour le troisième il
ya le choix redonner des douze lettres
ces 26 facteur est / 14 factorielle
l'ordre des supers ne compte pas au / 6
factorielle l'ordre dans chaque paire
mais n'importe pas faux / 206 et c'est
là que l'enregistrement un peu foiré
donc toutes mes excuses mais désolé
aussi pour le live pour ceux qui ont
essayé de se connecter
ça peut marcher le wifi a pas été assez
bon on s'en doute bref
donc je vais finir ma présentation et
après il y aura celle de la zone qui
était bien enregistrée
donc le nombre de configurations que
l'on a de la machine enigma et si on
fait les quelques 10 puissance 16 ça
c'était en fait avant 1939 en 1939 l'onf
a tué plus de records qui ont été
ajoutés plus de câble pour relier les
lettres fait on avait huit rotor après
1939 notamment dans la marine nazis du
coup ça laisse huit choix pour le
premier rotor 7 pour le second et 6 pour
le troisième et il y avait maintenant
dit câble pour voir où il est donc vain
lettres et son cas ça modifie pas les
chiffres que vous voyez est au final ça
fait pas mal plus de configuration sont
fait 9 x 10 puissance 20 et bien sûr
qu'on ne peut pas tout tout les tester à
la main ceci dit nigma n'était pas
indéchiffrables et en fait
turing notamment a réussi à déchiffrer
et nima si c'est le cas c'est à cause de
deux propriétés de faiblesse une non dès
demain la première c'est que les
messages envoyés par les nazis ne sont
pas arbitraire et ça ça va permettre de
savoir quels sont les types de messages
que l'on doit obtenir lorsqu'on les a
décodé et l'autre propriété l'autre
faiblesse qui est plus d'un machine
enigma c'est le fait que toutes les
permutations que tu utilises énigmes en
fait ne sont pas arbitrées raisons
certaines propriétés en particulier sont
des produits de transposition mais ça je
vais laisser razvan vous en parler
bonjour je m'appelle rassemble la gauche
aussi co organisateur du concours al
kindi
je vous parlais de comment on a cassé
uniquement on va voir qu'il ya plein de
mathématiques dedans donc d'abord il
faudra que je vous rappelle ce que c'est
une permutation parce que ce n'est pas
au programme du bac
enfin si je vais vous parler des
machines uniquement un site commence a
été cassé par les polonais et ensuite
par les anglais parce que ça a été serré
dans cet entrelacs donc une permutation
c'est une façon d'arranger un objet donc
tout simplement les mathématiciens volvo
la représenter en écrivant les objets en
eau et ensuite on on écrit les objets
dans leur nouvel ordre et voilà par
exemple en vendant 2 2 dans trois 3 ans
et 4 et 5 sont inversés et ensuite on
peut parler de la permutation vers c'est
ce que vous voyez ce que ça devrait être
c'est là le fait de remettre à plat ce
en place les objets
donc si havas dans b&b dans ses essais
dans as
pour trouver la permutation inverse je
dois dessiner des flèches rouges et
ensuite je prends la symétrie axiale de
sa belle c'est la permutation verse donc
si si si à aller dans b la permutation
anvers envoie bedan à d'accord et
certaines personnes les informaticiens
pour calculer la permutation envers
siphon la chaux ciment
ils écrivent la permutation ensuite ils
échangent les deux lignes comme ça et
ensuite il
la partie haute n'est pas bien elle doit
être dans le contre
trier et ce n'est pas le cas donc on va
trier la partie haute et c'est bon et ça
c'est la permutation anvers
c'est comme ça qu'on fait sur six poules
devraient quelqu'un nous demandent de
calculer des permutations 20 sont
fécondes sens et c'est un théorème
mathématique qui dit si vous appliquez
une permutation incite la permutation
verse par définition vous arrive et ça
revient en alliant faire mais par contre
un tout petit peu moins évident c'est le
fait que si vous commencez par appliquer
la permutation anvers
ensuite la permutation normal ça revient
aussi à rien faire parce que vous
appliquez la permutation rouge incite la
permutation noir les cheveux rouges
incident flèche noire ça revient quand
même à rien faire est une question qui
arrive souvent donc quelque chose qui
apparaît très naturellement sur les
permutations c'est imaginez vous que
vous avez une équipe de joueurs de foot
qui sont assis dans un bus un site vous
dit celui qui a aussi réagi qui sont
assis sur une rangée de cinéma un site
vous dit celui qui est assis sur la
position à 1 doit aller sur la position
10 ensuite vous dit celui qui est sous
la pression du doigt les sur la position
3 et ainsi de suite et vous répéter
répéter répéter répéter la permutation
au bout d'un moment ils vont revenir à
leur place de départ tous mais on peut
se poser la question
quelles sont les places sur lequel à
être a été à des moments différents
le footballeur numéro pente donc si je
regarde la permutation que j'avais au
départ
si je regarde qu'est ce qui se passe
avec le numéro un
je veux voir qu'il va arriver c'est la
position de j'applique de nouveau la
permutation il va délaisser la position
3 j'applique de nouveau il arrive c'est
la position en la permutation qui envoie
un sur deux sur 3,3 sur un an elle va
faire ça donc du coup on ne sera jamais
c'est la potion centre est là je fais
une typo comme bien 4 va arriver c'est
la position 5
ensuite quatre ans 8,5 ensuite quatre 4
5 cents sur la même orbite en de trois
cents sur la même orbite
c'est un peu comme dans le système
solaire vous avez des planètes que
chacune leur orbite sont les astéroïdes
qui partagent tous une orbite pour les
permutations séparer les éléments sont
groupés dans des orbites et il ya
quelque chose qui compte pour s
intéresser c'est quelle est la taille
des orbites d'une permutation par
exemple la permutation qui ne fait rien
la permutation identité et la crête des
orbites de longueur 1 par contre la
permutation qui envoie tout le monde sur
son suivant notre ancien de 2 3 3 sur 4
ainsi de suite
elle a mis seuls arbitres qui implique
tout le monde il contient tout le monde
donc à une permutation on lui associe
quelque chose qu'on dirait son poids
une propriété qui lui correspond et
s'appliquer s'appelle le motif de
décomposition nous le soutiendrons que
les mathématiciens autant vanter parce
que c'est intéressant et c'est amusant
mais on verra que ça des implications
pour énigme donc comment ça a commencé
et uniquement ma c'est ce que relève
haut à raconter
on veut contrecarrer al kindi donc pour
contre carrer al kindi on utilise une
substitution pour je suis fait la
première lettre une deuxième
substitution pour la deuxième lettre
troisième substitution pour la troisième
lettre et ça on pourrait normalement le
faire avec un cahier sur lequel on a
écrit une substitution ce chaque page et
on tourne les pages mais c'est fatigant
donc on utilise des machines pour faire
ça et l'idée ça a été donc a été créé
par un ingénieur qui s'appelait sérieuse
donc hallyday au début il ya eu entre
vers 1918 mais la commercialisation et
1,23 1923 et son idée c'était assez
pacifique comme démarche lui il voulait
tout simplement que les entreprises
commerciales garde le secret industriel
donc il communique les ingénieurs d'une
entreprise qui sont des mercedes aurait
pu communiquer de façon chiffrée et pour
cela ça coûtait 30 l'équivalent de
trente mille euros pour l'acheter mais
c'était un échec énorme
personne n'a acheté la machine donc
personne personnes pendant trois ans
sauf que d'après trois ans était le
grand lot à 3 ans et l armée allemande
qui a acheté hélas était il devenu tout
d'un coup très dur très important en
1931 le ministère français de la défense
a fait une taupe chez les services
secrets allemands et obtenu les plans
d'énigmes donc ils ont ils savent
exactement comment son câble et les
machines uniquement en 1933 les mac les
mathématiciens polonais casse les codes
et il commence déjà ils peuvent lire les
messages militaires des allemands c'est
juste que scéniquement étaient amis
modifiez petit à petit tout au long de
la guerre donc au début de la guerre
la machine était déjà cassée mais ces
modifications n'étaient pas cassé donc
les anglais devait encore cassé et à
les anglais le gouvernement anglais est
allé dans les universités et ils vont
embaucher
des mathématiciens donc c'est un peu les
gens on peut parler lui les
mathématiciens peu dans leur monde qui
font de belles choses pour leur beauté
et quand c'est la guerre on va on va
faire appel à que c'est assez bizarre
comme situation
et ils ont pour l'occasion ils ont
construit l'ordinateur colossus qui est
le premier ordinateur du monde qui a été
utilisé pour de vrai donc deux ans
auparavant les allemands avaient fait un
ordinateur mais c'était seulement pour
le mettre au musée le premier ordinateur
qui a résolu des tâches importantes
c'était colossus pour casser les codes
et allemand
donc comment ça marche uniquement en
fait trop fait face à ça ressemble à une
machine à écrire en clavier et du coup
il ya besoin de deux soldats pour
envoyer le message il ya un soldat qui
tape le message qui lie sur le papier il
tape et un deuxième candidat qui a des
limites
ici ce sont des lumières qui s'allument
par exemple quand on appuie sur la
touche
ah on va voir le elle qui s'allument
dans ce cas-là 2 le deuxième soldat
barreau t elle
donc c'est le code et en plus ensuite il
a il envoyait par par la radio la
technologie pour envoyer par la radio
c'était très très bien connu et c'est
très facile il ya même des radioamateurs
et ensuite il a écouté la radio les
autres sur la bonne fréquence et il
compilait et contre les anglais donc y
compris les ennemis tout le monde va
écouter la radio
et là il avait le message qui fait qu'on
ait un mort seulement envoyé accessoires
de mode et des très courts et longs et à
la fin une personne taper le message
reçu par exemple à pied sur la lettre l
essai telle ampoule à quissac qui
s'allumaient donc la machine réglée de
façon d'une certaine façon permettait de
chiffrer et permettait de déchiffrer
et donc il y avait des réglages
possibles c'est la machine enigma qui a
été fait chaque matin donc chaque matin
à minuit chaque jour à minuit
donc avis très tôt en tentant quelques
salles ont commencé par branches et des
câbles qui correspondait à échanger des
lettres un site ont réglé des retour à
une certaine position donc les anglais
connaissait exactement comment il était
fait la machine enigma connaissait les
câblages ce qu'il ne savait pas c'était
qu'elle est la combinaison des trois
roues qu'on appelle vos torts dans quel
ordre les a placés et quel est son
iphone à relier et ce qui se passe c'est
que on appuie sur la touche ah il ya un
fil qui commence à exister ya une
relation via un fil qui relie la lettre
a parlait retour les retombées des
mélanges pas céder mélange on a un film
qui se créent les rotors ce sont des
jeux tant que chaque roue il ya des fils
électriques et ce sont les fils book
aller-retour bouge les connexions se
font différemment
donc il ya d'autres chemins qui
apparaissent et qui disparaissent quand
on tourne les roues donc au moment
initial où on à la lettre à
il ya un chemin qui passe par les rotors
arrive dans une pièce qui ne fait qu'à
relier
une lettre avec une autre après un repas
ce retrouve en chemin par les retours et
trouve nul est par exemple j'ai une fois
que à la fin du mois pile après le g
salue mais la machine à ya une roue qui
a tourné
donc du coup il ya d'autres chemins qui
apparaissent et du coup à sera chiffré
par ses dents le la position suivante
d'accord on n'a pas besoin de beaucoup
de plus que ça c'est tout ça c'est c'est
tout ce qu'il nous faut pour comprendre
ce qui sait que comme la casse est donc
là je vais schématiser uniquement je
vais dire les câblages mélange les
lettres applique un termite à sion et
que ce que je représente part du bleu
par le trapèze bleu ensuite il ya des
choses bizarres ce qui se passe dans les
retours mais ça ça m'intéresse parce que
je dessine juste en trapèze jeunes et
ensuite on repasse par la permutation
par les câblages mais à l'envers
donc je dessinais l'image de l'envers
parce que c'est dans le sens inverse en
quelque sorte et donc du coup quand on
appuie sur la lettre
sur l'une des lettres on passe par le
bleu on passe par le jaune on y va et on
revient un site on repasse par le bleu
donc comment l'école et polonais ont
fait pour casser ils avaient cassé ça
avant la guerre donc les allemands
commencer par régler leurs machines et
ensuite pour chaque message échangé le
réglage chaque message est envoyé avec
son propre sa propre position des
retours donc impossible de cas c'est
vraiment
c'est chaque message alexandre
chiffrement par contre avant de renvoyer
le vrai message on envoyait la position
des trois auteurs ont commencé par
envoyer trois lettres qui correspondait
à la position des trois rotors et parce
qu'il avait peur que ça se transmettent
mal par la réunion n'entama le entre et
l'on devient très court il ne l est qui
le mettait deux fois donc qu'est ce
qu'il faisait il écrivait deux fois le
clip est par exemple abc abc il le
chiffre est avec énigmes ans et ils
envoyaient ensuite il réglait la machine
avec ce nouveau réglage avec les
réglages abc et ensuite ils envoyaient
le vrai message
les polonais ils ont utilisé seulement
les six premières lettres de chaque
message donc seulement les abc abc moi
je vais les appeler alfa-beta alfa beta
donc du coup le message la situation
ressemble à ça disons que les polonais
ont vu écrire azerty hasard tu es au pq
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que ils ont chiffré alfa-beta gamme alfa
beta gamma et puis des choses qui ne
nous intéresse pas il oublie tout ce qui
se passe là c'est trop dur on oublie ça
en garde comme ça et on se rend compte
que ar sushis sont les chiffres de la
même lettre
donc du coup on va faire un petit peu de
pharmaciens géométriques je renverse
je fais une copie de leur donc imaginer
que ça c'est la machine uniquement dans
la position initiale ça c'est la machine
uniquement trois positions plus tard
qu'est ce qui se passe dans magne dans
mon imagination je fais la chose
suivante jean verse la machine je la
dessine comme ça je retourne à langer le
doigt ainsi je la mène là
donc du coup ce que ce que les polonais
faisait ce qu'il mettait deux machines
enigma côte à côte
donc il ne m'était aucun câblage
n'émettait aucun câblage par contre ils
essayaient toutes les combinaisons des
retours ils essayaient toutes les
combinaisons de rotor qui sont pas si
nombreuses que sont pas si nombreuses
qu'il ya seulement dix sept mille mais
pour ça mais pour ça ils ont fait une
machine une machine testée 17000 ces
cinq minutes en fait dix-sept mille
c'est rien comparé aux milliards de
milliards de milliards qui auraient si
on prenait en compte les câblages qui
prenait en compte seulement les les
triplettes des rotors et il les essayer
tous et pour chacun
il mettait la machine uniquement dans la
position correspondante
ensuite il utilisait la machine enigma
pendant trois positions conquises à pied
trois fois sur n'importe quel droit il a
frappé trois fois sur la triplette alfa
beta gamma et il obtenait la machine
rouge et ensuite il branché bout à bout
deux machines uniquement donc on essaye
tout les triplettes par exemple
revêtissent tester les triplé a baissé
je tape à baisser sur la machine enigma
j'obtiens énigmes à trois positions plus
tard elle met deux copies des l'image
les branches boutabout ça ça devient une
composition de permutations sans mélange
vraiment bien les lettres mais du coup
qu'est ce qui se passe on obtient le
d100 suivant qu'est ce que ça fait aux
lettres ça les fait passer par les
câblages ça les fait passer par les
retours rouge ça les fait passer par les
câblages de nouveau par les câblages
sens inverse un site pas les retours
vers un site par les câblages donc du
coup l'idée c'est que ça disparaît dans
l'imitation prix permutations
ça s'annule donc en fait on sait très
bien que l'effet de la permutation verte
puis la permutation rouge mais on sait
on sait disons que la lettre r et la
lettre à son le chiffre est de la même
de alpha sont tous les deux chiffres et
d'un même lettre donc on sait qu'on a un
chemin qui passe comme ça donc
l'information qu'on récupère ses
colosses le chiffre est de r est envoyé
sur les chiffres et de a donc voilà tout
ça tout le travail c'est pour dire le
chiffre est deux airs par le câblage est
envoyé par une certaine permutations
dans les chiffres et de à ça dit pas si
grandes choses que ça parce qu'on sait
pas qui est ce que ça veut dire j'ai
fait deux erreurs chiffre est deux ans
on sait pas lequel sait mais est ce que
vous vous rappelez qu'est ce que c'était
que les orbites d'une permutation donc
les les allemands envoyait beaucoup de
messages par jour
imaginez-vous qu'ils envoyaient ils sont
200 messages par jour peut-être le 2000
messages par jour donc avec les 2000
messages par jour
on avait le temps de ramasser plan-plan
plan-plan l'information
on savait que le chiffre est de herb
assure le chiffre est de a ensuite que
les chiffres de havas sur le chiffre est
de ces et ainsi de suite on voyait
qu'elle est là la orbite de chiffres et
de m-16 pensable que la orbite de
chiffres et de r à longueur disons
centre donc on savait quelle est la
taille des orbites de la terre mutation
verte puis rouge
voilà donc du coup ce qui se passe que
les polonais faisait il essayait de
produire la permutation vert depuis
rouge c'est-à-dire y mettait la machine
est uniquement sans aucun câblage et
tester toutes les triplets verts ils
calculaient qu'est ce que ça veut dire
que tu perds rouge tout en même temps ça
coûte rien donc il obtenait cette
permutation et il voyait si elle a la
bonne taille des orbites ou pas
c'est comme si pour casser un site
internet vous avez besoin de demande de
mot de passe et vous décidez de ne pas
essayer en des mots de passe vous
concentrer seulement sur le premier est
le site internet vous dis oui c'est le
bon c'est lui c'est le bon mot de passe
ou pas ou c'est pas le bon mot de passe
vous avez le droit de tester un mot de
passe à la fois
imaginez vous que vous avez deux mots de
passe à deviner un site qui vous dit le
premier mot de passe est correct ou pas
vous aident énormément parce que vous
allez tester c'est d'abord le premier
mot de passe et ensuite le deuxième de
manière indépendante pas en même temps
et du coup donc les polonais ils
testaient toutes les îles commencer par
trouver quels sont les tailles des
orbites de la permutation rouge verte
ensuite ils testaient toutes les
triplettes donc 17 milles 576 et pour
chacune il calculait qu'est ce que ça
fait
rouge + pivert et calculer sa taille des
orbites qui s'était pas la bonne il a
jeté à la poubelle
il y avait seulement quelques-unes
disons une ou deux maximum 3 qui
survivaient qui est telle qu'il trouvait
là le réglage des lettres
une fois les réglages de lettres
retrouvées il fallait encore tomber les
câblages mais on a réussi à le travail
qu'il faut faire c'est d'abord trouver
les les triplettes des rotors ensuite
trouver les câblages et le nombre de
câblage et celui ci donc on obtient un
certain nombre d'essais qu'ils
arrivaient à faire disons dans
dans très peu de temps j'ai besoin d'au
moins d'un jour alors que s'il avait eu
à tester en même temps toutes les
réglages possibles de et uniquement ça
aurait été en fait pas fiable on est de
l'ordre de 4 milliards de possibilités
et ensuite les polonais en fait je sais
pas si vous vous rappelez l'histoire de
la première guerre mondiale c'est le
premier pays qui a été envahi pendant la
guerre donc ils ont et après trois
semaines
le pays a été content hier quand kelly
donc ils ont donné rendez vous aux
anglais dans la forêt et ils ont donné
tous leurs travaux
il leur a expliqué comment il fait ils
leur ont donné toute leur note
exactement comment ils font pour pour
casser uniquement et du coup quand les
mathématiciens anglais ont été recrutés
on leur a dit déjà il faut utiliser
il faut vous pouvez faire comme ça
qu'est ce qu'ils sont pas partis de zéro
ils sont partis de sa et par exemple ils
ont gardé le nom le nom des machines les
machines que les polonais utilisent et
faisait énormément de bruit donc ils les
ont appelés des bombes
parce qu'elle était énormément de bruit
et les anglais ont gardé par exemple ça
en général
l'idée de la méthode de travail le fait
qu'il faut construire un ordinateur qui
imite énigmes en saas a été gardée par
exemple le problème pourquoi les anglais
ont dû refaire du travail c'est parce
que les allemands ont tard était de
commencer leur message par alfa beta
gamma alfa beta gamma
ils ont arrêté d'envoyer le triplé ils
ont créé une substitution des 10 grammes
donc ils ont créé méthode de chiffrement
très simple qui faisait sur papier et
qui n'étaient utilisés pas du tout sauf
pour ça donc au moment où quelqu'un fait
une méthode de chiffrement qu'il utilise
seulement pour très peu de caractère
dans toute l'histoire dans toute la
haute l'utilisation et les calculs sont
faits à la main là ils ont pas pu casser
ça les anglais donc on n'a jamais su
comment il chiffrait les triplets
comment il s'appelle la position des
énigmes donc on est en passe de la
situation tous les messages de la
journée chiffres pareils on passe à la
situation chaque message chifflet avec
son propre réglages s'accordent donc on
utilisait le réglage des machines
quotidien uniquement pour envoyer le
triplet qu'on a déjà chiffré sur papier
et du coup voilà donc la seule chose qui
restait aux anglais d'utiliser c'était
le fait que les angles les messages
étaient prévisibles
il y avait des soldats qui était très
très content très soucieux qu'ils
commençaient leur journée par
j'espère par préparé par vérifier que
tout en plaçant s'utiliser le le cahier
de énigmes ans il regarde quel est le
code il réglait la machine enigma sa
place après il était tellement content
qu'ils ont tous bien fait et il envoyait
un petit message pour faire un test
est ce que ça marche bien et le message
c'était rien à déclaré jean qu'il y
avait des gens qui étaient trop
pointilleux la cause de soi de ça ça a
été cassé quelque chose que les
allemands ont essayé de faire quand se
sont rendus compte c'est d'introduire
des langage texto
donc il faisait des raccourcis dans les
messages mais le problème c'est que
chaque personne a ses propres raccourcis
donc du coup les anglais qui écoutait
les messages transmis par la radio ils
s'étaient habitués au style de chaque
soldat qui savaient qu'un soldat et plus
nerveux un soldat est plus calme et
organes et reconnaissait il disait à ce
message là c'est lui l huile a
l'habitude de l'abréger comme ça il a de
faire ça qu'ils savaient exactement quel
est le message
et ça ça s'appelle the cribs crible
normalement c'est un objet qui te
quelque chose qui te permet de saisir un
objet donc forcément il faudrait une
fois que tu as trouvé une place et le
message passe ici fille de tester toutes
les positions de uniquement
mais est ce qu'on peut faire des petites
des accélérations en fait turing c'est l
inventeur de l'ordinateur l'ordinateur
n'existait pas en fait
mais comme c'étaient l'ordinateur de
l'ordinateur il avait créé quelque chose
qui s'appelle et machine de turing de
façon théorique les le monde académique
était très content mais après c'était ce
que pour de vrai ton truc marche porter
machine manche là il a été capable de
superviser la construction d'un
ordinateur et vous dites mais oui mais
l'ordinateur premier ordinateur c'est
plutôt dans les années 60 ceignac
comment et pourquoi je dis que c'était
dans les années 40 c'est pas une
contradiction là quand on parle du
premier ordinateur
je crois que c'est plutôt dans les
années 60
en fait c'est tout simple les militaires
ont eu peur de l'ordinateur ils ont dit
c'est quelque chose de trop puissant
donc ils ont donné ordre à détruire
toutes les marques toutes les
ordinateurs utilisés pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale y compris les plans
aujourd'hui il y à un musée de blegny
pas où il expose des ordinateurs de
l'époque mais c'est parce qu'il ya eu
des survivants qui ont raconté comment
ça marchait donc c'était la mémoire des
gens qui ont travaillé sur les
ordinateurs qui a permis de reconstruire
les ordinateurs mais sinon on les avait
détruit et pendant 50 ans était interdit
d'en parler
les anglais avaient réussi à cracker
double à vous puisque les anglais est ce
que c'est que d'autres futurs ennemis ce
petit utilisé uniquement à être ils ont
été capables de pratiquer sans qui ces
équipes il ya eu des compagnies privées
qui ont utilisé pour le secret industrie
secrets industriels qui ont utilisé
uniquement des années 50 60
mais vous même dans la diplomatie
certains pays y ont utilisé uniquement
après la guerre donc voilà donc ce qui
est important c'était d'utiliser des
ordinateurs et si les allemands
faisaient l'erreur d'envoyer le message
rien à signaler ou rapporte métro ça le
reconnaît 20 minutes pour casser donc en
fait on sait pas justement parce que
c'était interdit parce que c'est le
secret militaire de parler de qu'est-ce
que ça s'est passé mais c'est non on
peut quand même deviner que c'était un
peu approximativement un message sur
deux ou un jour sur deux c'est les
anglais pouvaient lire les messages des
allemands donc pendant toute la guerre
pendant la guerre il avait un avantage
par rapport à leurs ennemis savait ce
qu'il allait faire
et du coup comment on va pouvait
uniquement parce que disons qu'à
utiliser l'ordinateur pour casser ça
prends ma minute mais je sais que c'est
le mort rapporte météo qu'il faut
classer mais si j'ai reçu un message qui
vais 200 positions
je dois tester ma machine avec la forme
et hauts placés ici
ensuite avec le rapport météo placé à
droite plus à droite et ainsi de sic
donc je dois utiliser le calcul qui dure
20 minutes
deux cents fois ce qui fait dépasser les
24 heures ce qui donne non seulement le
temps de changer leur code uniquement
donc rien que de trouver où est ce qu'on
va placer
le mot rapport météo c'est extrêmement
important
et là les anglais ont trouvé l'idée
suivante qu'ils ont regardé comment
marche la machine enigma et ils se sont
rendus compte que à cause de son
fonctionnement électronique
il était impossible qu'une lettre soit
chiffré par elle-même il est impossible
qu'une lettre ne cherche pas
donc du coup si j'essaye de placer le
mot rapport météo ici ce n'est pas bon
parce que tu es devrait être ce chiffre
et partez ensuite là ce n'est pas bon
parce que au sur les chiffres et pas
trop là c'est bon là ça pourrait être
vrai là c'est pas bon parce que c'était
sur les chiffres est par terre là c'est
pas beau encore cause de terre est là
c'est pas beau en cause 2 ap et donc une
observation assez simple le fait que
l'être n'a pas le droit d'être chiffré
par elle-même ça permet de
réduire beaucoup le travail donc c'est
sûr que les disait la machine ne fait
pas toutes les permutations possible et
du coup ce travail là ils étaient faits
par des défis sans papiers qui
produisait à une ville à côté qui
s'appelle un village à côté qui
s'appelle banbury et il faisait glisser
des fiches et juste à l'oeil nu
on voyait ou est-ce que ça doit coller
ou pas et du coup comme c'est assez
amusant de le faire ça s'appelait en
bambou risme parce que ça sonnait le nom
rassemble à ce que c'est tu fais glisser
une feuille de papier et tu casses une
machine super bien fait ça c'est assez
ridicule et bien sûr turing aujourd'hui
donne le nom du prix le plus prestigieux
prix en informatique
c'est le prix turing c'est l'équivalent
du prix nobel parce que non seulement il
a inventé les ordinateurs de machines de
façon théorique
ensuite il a supervisé la construction
des premiers ordinateurs qui a vraiment
fonctionné
et ensuite il a fait un travail de
développeurs des programmeurs donc il a
trouvé des astuces sur comment accélérer
les calculs c'est la chose suivante
aujourd'hui ça a l'air assez normal
c'est la chose suivante imaginez-vous
que on vous donne à chacun une
combinaison de uniquement et vous devez
tester si elle est possible ou pas si en
combinaison anti play de lettres est
possible ou pas et vous allez faire des
essais sur votre brouillon vous allez
dire si havas dans w alors doublement
mal en eux
il ya des informations que vous pouvez
très déterminé et ensuite vous fait des
calculs vous faites sur votre brouillon
ah oui ça c'est pas possible ça c'est
pas possible
et tout d'un coup vous chaque rang
assemble sa propre transformation est ce
que tu ring a eu comme idée est donc
uniquement c'était des petites machines
qui étaient toutes positionnelle l'une à
côté de l'autre
et qu'ils aient chacune ses propres
calculs son idée c'était de l'écho de
les connecter les unes aux autres de
façon qu'elles partagent leurs
brouillons
une fois que vous avez fait donc quand
vous faites des calculs sur votre
bouillon vous trouvez que le fait que
havas dans tes c'est pas possible
par exemple alors il faut qu'elle
personne n'essaye plus tard la
combinaison avant d'enter tout le monde
doit utiliser l'information que vous
avez déjà essayé
voilà donc ça c'était le grand génie de
turing c'est un peu comme si quelqu'un
non seulement il inventait la
motocyclette
mais ensuite il devenait le champion du
monde de motocyclettes de deux couches
de motocyclettes
c'est non seulement il a commencé par
mettre les bases ensuite il a construit
pour de vrai et ensuite il a fait des
avancées sur comment utiliser
l'ordinateur
voilà c'est tout est-ce que vous avez
des questions donc déjà donc juste
rendement les polonais ont cassé passe
grâce à la taille des orbites essai de
mathématiques c'est la taille des
orbites et cdma moitié et les anglais
c'était beaucoup plus dur parce que les
allemands s'était amélioré entre temps
et c'est avant tout de l'informatique
qu'ils ont fait voilà ma merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est à dire de mon talent sur de
l'importance de la cryptographie et
informatique est fan mais là tu te
gratter aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
centrales dans le monde tout ce qui se
passe sur internet dès mon boulot j'ai
sur facebook
donc en gros le message sur mon sort et
rixson langue à quelqu'un gamme de
sacoches ou l'autre tous les messages
sont encodées avec des méthodes
cryptographiques qui sont beaucoup plus
développés que ça c'est beaucoup plus
mathématique aussi en turquie tps ps sur
l'ordinateur solitaire est d'habitude
vous voyez http est capable
à la fin ça veut dire https utiliser ça
veut dire qu'on utilise un chiffrement
pour tout ce qui est communication et le
chiffrement
c'est quelque chose de similaire là
uniquement il faudra se partager des
photos très compliqué de prévenir tout
en réduisant les premiers ministres ont
par exemple il commence à faire de la
photographie de petites énigmes
peut-être un peu plus pragmatique mais
ça peu paradoxal donc quelque chose qui
a été développé il est utilisé par
marielle en fait est utilisé aujourd'hui
suite
en fait c'est encore un problème de
maths pouvait retrouver mathématiquement
que ce genre de code est vraiment
sécurisée est en fête avec les
ordinateurs quantiques
c'est mal au coeur c'est pas sécurisé
heureusement ses points forts il ya
encore énormément de recherches
mathématiques de pointe vraiment avisé
grosse grosse découverte encore à faire
quoi sur ce genre de questions
c'est pour ça
c'est pour ça que je sais qui c'est
voilà merci